alors qu'une introduction pareil j'ai un
peu la pression
j'ai aussi la passion parce que vous
sortez votre déjeuner donc je vais
essayer de vous réveiller la pression je
n'ai eu de laurent je suis ravi que ce
soit lui qui m'est présenté je suis
ravie aussi qui m'est fait venir
simplement quand il m'a demandé de
parler de l'ambition au féminin là je me
suis posé la question et moi je n'ai
jamais eu d'ambition
j'ai jamais eu d'ambition
c'était mal vu ça l'est encore en
particulier quand on est une femme
c'est un peu curieux le vocabulaire
ambitions nom féminin en français dans
beaucoup d'autres langues aussi
simplement quand on dit d'une femme
qu'elle est ambitieuse
c'est assez rarement pour lui faire un
compliment s'est déplacé à la limite de
l'inconvenant alors je n'ai jamais eu
d'ambition
c'est vrai aussi qu'on en n'a pas
forcément eu pour moi au départ ni
autour de moi ni à l'école alors on
pourrait se dire que c'était il ya
quelques années ont très peu d'années
pas forcément
je ne suis pas sûr que les choses aient
beaucoup changé je suis même un peu sûr
du contraire puisque aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance de travailler pour et avec de
jeunes hommes et de jeunes femmes dans
l'entourage familial qu'est ce qu'on
attend d'une petite fille qu'elle soit
jolie qu'elle soit j'en tire qu'elle
soit sage qu'elle soit calme et qu'elle
soit altruiste et d'ailleurs pour
aboutir à tout ça on ne lui donne pas
exactement les mêmes jouer qu'au petit
garçon pour lequel on a déjà d'autres
gens d'attentes pas les mêmes jouets et
pas les mêmes lectures et ça c'est plus
récent
si vous allez dans une librairie et que
vous cherchez le rayon livres pour
enfants vous n'allez pas le trouver vous
allez trouver un rayon livres pour
petits garçons et puis un rayon livres
pour petites filles vous ne risquez pas
de
vous trompez un rayon et bleu l'autre et
rose très très rose et les ti gars on va
leur donner à lire des histoires de
chevaliers de kobri de corsair tout ce
qui vous donne envie de partir à la
conquête du monde
pendant ce temps là les petites filles
on va leur donner à lire des histoires
de princesses et est exclusivement des
histoires de princesses est-ce que ça
forge les mêmes rêves
est-ce que ça construit les mêmes
ambitions
pas forcément alors heureusement il y à
l'école et l'école c'est le royaume des
filles les filles sont bonnes élèves
très bon élève tête de classe je le sais
j'en ai été une
heureusement je m'en suis sortie c'est
ce qui m'a sauvé
et alors si elles sont têtes de classe
l'école leur didonne d'aussi bonnes
notes c'est forcément que l'école a pour
elle un projet d attente
une ambition forcément
pas si sûr qu'est ce que les professeurs
m
chez les petites filles est viré même
chose que ce qu'on aime
à la maison elle son calme beaucoup plus
calme que les garçons elles sont moins
contestataire elles suivent les
consignes elle les applique
en bref elles ont une qualité formidable
elles sont reposantes
c'est ça qui fait qu'elles ont des
bonnes notes
alors ça c'est ce qu'on vit tous les
jours
manière un peu plus scientifique je suis
posé la question de savoir si nos
enseignants et surtout nos enseignantes
puisque dans la petite enfance ce sont
surtout les femmes qui enseigne aux
enfants avaient tout à fait les mêmes
attentes
les mêmes ambitions pour les petits
garçons et pour les petites filles
je me suis posée puis j'ai demandé à des
chercheurs de l'éducation de regarder un
petit peu ce que une enseignante le
matin demande à la petite fille qui
arrivent en classe et c'est assez simple
assez systématique on va lui demander de
réciter la leçon de la veille ça
développe toute une série de compétences
écoutez s'appliquer retenir et récités
et si vous faites tout ça dans l'ordre
ça se passe très bien
c'est sans risque sans exposition sans
mauvaise surprise à la sortie vous êtes
gratifié pendant ce temps là qu'est ce
qu'on va demander aux petits garçons
vous savez que les garçons sont les mal
aimés du système scolaire se sont même
ceux qu'on appelle les décrocheurs 82%
des décrocheurs de notre système
scolaire qui sortent de l'école sans
diplôme sans formation sont des garçons
alors naturellement les enseignants vont
s'interroger en permanence comment faire
pour que le garçon ne décroche pas ne
met pas la pagaille dans le cours reste
attentif alors pour garder l'attention
d'un petit garçon on va pas lui demander
de réciter la leçon de la veille c'est
quand même extraordinairement ennuyeux
on va lui demander d'inventer de deviner
ce dont on a parlé dans la journée
et qu'est ce qu'il va faire pour ça il
va se souvenir de ce qu'il a lu de ce
qu'il a vu de ce qu'il a entendu
ailleurs il va faire appel à des
connaissances qui l'aura acquise en
dehors de l'école dans le vrai monde
dans la vraie vie
et puis veille faire appel il va se
lancer il a essayé y va oser il va
s'exposer
il va prendre un risque mais dans le
fond il va prendre un tout petit risque
parce que s'ils deviennent juste sera
félicité
puis s'ils se trompent va quand même pas
lui en vouloir
ça n'était jamais que la leçon à venir
le pauvre ne pouvait pas savoir
alors à ce tarif 15 ans d'éducation
est-ce que nous sommes sûrs que ça fait
tout à fait les mêmes compétences
les mêmes rêves les mêmes ambitions pour
les petits garçons et pour les petites
filles
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça ne donne pas
le même résultat
les filles sortent triomphante du
système scolaire
soixante pour cent des diplômés de
master en europe et en france sont des
femmes
triomphe absolu quelques années plus
tard 12 % des dirigeants sondés
dirigeante
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
que le monde merveilleux de l'école
s'est envolé la vraie vie est arrivé
alors on le sait on le dit on nous le
répète les femmes ne candidate pas à des
postes ne demande pas une promotion ne
vendent pas une augmentation beaucoup
moins que les hommes on nous répète à
l'envi que un homme qui à 50% des
compétences va oser poste proposé sa
candidature pour un poste là où une
femme qui a 100% des mêmes compétences
va hésiter et nous les femmes on entend
cette petite musique elle nous fait
assez plaisir on trouve ça assez
satisfaisant moralement supérieure on
aurait une modestie naturelle qui nous
conduirait la différence des garçons à
prendre du recul a hésité avant de vous
mettre en avant alors moi je ne crois
pas du tout à la modestie je crois au
contraire que c'est notre orgueil
d'anciennes bonne élève qui nous
paralyse quand on a toujours eu des
bonnes notes quand on a toujours été la
première parce qu'on respectait les
consignes qu'on s'applique est qu'on
était dans notre zone de confort
l'idée la simple idée d'essuyer un refus
de rencontrer un échec de prendre une
gifle de faire face à un obstacle nous
est tout simplement insupportable et ça
mesdames je suis désolé c'est de
l'orgueil ça rien à voir avec la
modestie
pourtant quand est ce qu'on apprend le
plus de choses si en faisant face à un
échec
quand est-ce qu'on grandit le mieux
c'est en surmontant un obstacle
c'est en s'exposant ses talents vers ce
qu'on ne connaît pas que l'on se
découvre en découvrant le monde
il ya une magnifique définition du
succès on la doit au winston churchill
plutôt pas mal réussi sa vie a priori et
qui disait le succès c'est d'aller
d'échec en échec sans jamais perdre son
enthousiasme
moi j'en ai fait ma devise est je me la
suis bien appliqué des échecs j'en ai
connu enthousiasme est toujours là
celui d'être avec vous aujourd'hui par
exemple et pas seulement ce que je
crains c'est qu'aucune femme n'aurait
été capable d'inventer cette phrase
l'a72 vise là tout simplement parce que
nous sommes très souvent trop souvent
englués dans notre piège de bonne élève
alors évidemment il ya des femmes qui
vont de l'avant pour qui les choses se
passent bien
si ce n'est que la bonne élève
la bonne élève la rattrape assez vite un
deuxième piège celui qui nous vient de
nos années d'école si merveilleuse
finalement malgré tout le piège de la
perfection nous sommes convaincus
intimement convaincu que ce qu'on nous
demande c'est d'être parfaite
en tout tout le temps de tout réussir
et alors après avoir lu les contes de
fées qui nous ont fait prendre un départ
assez contestable on enchaîne avec
les magazines féminins prenez à
magazines féminins et ne me dites pas
que vous les lisez pas messieurs vous
les lisez aussi parfois avant nous les
modèles que l'on nous met sous les yeux
sont extraordinaires la sonde elles sont
jeunes elles sont minces elles
réussissent tous leurs amours leurs
enfants alors lisez la maternité
expliqué dans un magazine féminin
bientôt il faudra avoir un doctorat pour
avoir des enfants est évidemment leur
vie professionnelle vous regardez ça
soit vous essayez de la ressembler et
vous êtes à peu près épuisées tout de
suite
soit vous êtes complètement découragé
alors qu'est ce que vous faites
continuez affûtez votre magazine et
puisque vous n'arrivez pas à être ses
modèles absolument éblouissant
totalement irréel et où tout est
photoshopée la photo mais leur ici aussi
alors puisque vous n'arrivez pas être ce
qu'on vous met sous les yeux vous
essayez d'avoir tout ce qu'on vous
propose comme signes extérieurs de
perfection petit tenir de perfection
vous allez acheter vite fait en vous
disant que ça vous rapproche de la
personne que vous avez vues dans votre
magazine féminin préféré et bien sûr le
marketing la publicité ont très bien
compris que essayer d'avoir quand on
n'arrive pas à être ça fait très bien
vendre et nous on court derrière ça on
s'épuise derrière ça et ça ne marche pas
très bien alors je me suis aussi demandé
qu'est ce qui faisait que certaines
femmes avaient franchi des barrières
l'avait arrêté d'être des bons élèves
comme moi et avait réussi à croire en
leur destin avait une ambition et là
encore on a travaillé des chercheurs la
réponse est une amine de toutes ces
femmes c'est la même c'est leur père qui
les a encouragés à être ce qu'elles sont
alors pas leur mère on sait ce qu'il en
est des rapports mère-fille par l'école
on l'a vu l'école adore les filles mais
pas forcément pour des bonnes raisons
dans leur père donc ayez un père
encourageant le monde vous appartient
soyez un père encourageants et votre
fille ira loin
je vous demande de méditer ce petit
conseil pensez par exemple à cette jeune
femme qui nous impressionne tout ce qui
est notre rôle modèle à tous celle qu'a
eue le prix nobel de la paix parce
qu'elle avait combattu risqué sa vie
pour que d'autres jeunes femmes puissent
aller à l'école mal à la malle à la
youssef sai malala est une femme
extraordinaire de courage
d'investissement de rayonnement de
charisme avant malala il ya eu le père
de mal à la c'est lui qui a commencé à
combattre pour que les petites filles
pakistanaises puissent aller à l'école
c'est lui qui a donné à sa fille le
courage de continuer donc messieurs
essayer tous d'être des pères de mal à
la et le monde s'en portera mieux alors
moi je n'ai pas une ambition je n'en
n'ai toujours pas mais j'ai d'autres
moteurs la passion la curiosité
ça m'a conduit aux quatre coins du monde
j'ai choisi un métier métier diplomate
plus beau métier qui puisse exister
celui dont on disait quand j'ai choisi
c'est un métier d'homme comme on parle
d'une boisson d'hommes vous savez et on
disait pas forcément fait pour une femme
savait pas qu'une femme ait les épaules
les épaules en diplomatie
je ne vois pas bien au football
américain j'arrive à comprendre des
épaules
la diplomatie c'est comprendre écouter
dialoguer convaincre les épaules
pas évident et puis quand je pense à des
femmes comme madeleine albright comme
condoleezza rice comme marc hillary
clinton
j'ai pas eu l'impression qu'il ya manque
de carrure qui les a empêchés d'être ce
qu'elles sont donc métier d'homme métier
de femme
là encore je n'ai pas écouté ce genre de
choses je n'ai pas regretté
j'ai eu des moments merveilleux d'autres
moments plus difficiles
j'ai décidé de tout choisir et notamment
de faire ce qu'on m'avait dit qu'il
serait impossible
on m'avait dit tu verras la diplomatie
c'est une vocation un sacerdoce un
vocabulaire à la fois religieux et très
masculin est donc impossible d'avoir une
vie personnelle
ça m'a un peu agacé du coup j'ai fondé
une famille j'ai eu quatre enfants
alors question qu'on me pose toute la
journée qu'on ne pose jamais un homme
dans la situation comment faites-vous
pour conseiller tout ça
moi je dis comment font-ils pour vivre
avec moi c'est eux qui sont admirables
moi je sais ce que je fais je fais tout
mal mais avec enthousiasme j'ai écouté
churchill et 7
honnêtement
et c'est honnêtement beaucoup plus
agréable pour moi je ne le cache pas et
je crois beaucoup plus supportables pour
eux alors aujourd'hui c'est tout ça qui
m'a conduit où je suis là où je suis
c'est à la tête d'une grande école
française ce qu'on appelle un peu vite
un peu avec agacement parfois je peux le
comprendre
une fabrique des élites dit comme ça
c'est intimidant surtout quand on n'est
pas soi même sorti la fabrique je vous
rassure et je tiens à vous le dire
aujourd'hui
préparez les élites de demain pour
quelqu'un comme moi c'est ne rien
oublier de ce qu'on a vécu avant c'est
s'efforcer de faire en sorte que les
élites de demain nous ressemblent
ressemble à la société au service de
laquelle ils vont se mettre c'est à dire
qu'elles soient beaucoup plus diverses
qu'elles ne l'ont été jusqu'à présent
beaucoup plus diverse de toutes les
manières possibles
qu'on arrête ce gâchis de talents et
notamment le talent des jeunes femmes
toutes ces femmes en qui on a cru qu'on
a formé il faut les pousser vers le haut
vers ce qu'elles peuvent donner parce
que ce qu'elles ont à apporter à notre
société
ce n'est pas des qualités féminines
qu'elle aurait ce qui voudrait dire
qu'elle aurait aussi des défauts féminin
c'est une diversité cette université
point de vue c'est une capacité à
interroger l'existant à mettre en cause
les routines le statu quo dans un monde
de complexité c'est de la diversité dont
on a besoin
hommes et femmes côte à côte
certainement pas pour que les femmes
prennent la place des hommes quelle
horreur j'avais lu un livre il ya
quelques années qui s'appelait la fin
des hommes pas ça dont on a envie qu'on
a envie c'est que les femmes prennent
leur place aux côtés des hommes pour
changer un monde dont on aura du mal à
nous dire qu'il est tellement
satisfaisant qu'il faudrait en rester au
statu quo hélas les femmes quelque chose
à apporter avec les sommes à leurs côtés
mon engagement et j'aimerais que ce soit
peut-être aussi le vôtre c'est faire en
sorte de réhabiliter ce beau mot
d'ambition dans ce qu'il veut vraiment
nous dit
et dire aux jeunes femmes et aux jeunes
hommes qui aspirent à faire quelque
chose de leur vie
l'ambition c'est servir à quelque chose
c'est se mettre au service des autres
c'est faire la différence là où on est
et ça doit pouvoir se décliner au
féminin autant qu'au masculin